clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi
saluons va waouh ça va toi ben pas trop
la regarde ces trucs qui m'ont poussé
sous les yeux là non ça je vois mais
c'est pas ça plus grave si j'en sais
rien moi c'est quoi ces trucs ça c'est
décernera on a quoi sa sert a alors à te
faire prendre conscience qu'il faudrait
que tu dormes un peu c'est pas le seul
indice clair
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on rigole on rigole mais il à
résoudre les cernes
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'ils foutent là de
quoi se mêle on va s'intéresser de près
à ce phénomène
pourquoi on a des cernes et pourquoi on
va s'intéresser à ce phénomène
vous même vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer
parce que faire alors pour commencer
qu'est ce que c'est un cerne oui parce
que premières infos c'est un mot
masculin comme testicules même si sorti
de là ça n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
un testicule
ou alors faudra qu'on soit très gonflé
une fois qu'on a acquis ce savoir
inestimable sur le genre des cernes
il reste quand même deux trois trucs à
apprendre pour mieux cerner le problème
d'abord il ya plusieurs types de cernes
qui découlent de cause très différentes
et du coup qui implique des soins et des
traitements très différent évidemment
enfin si on a envie de les faire
disparaître un parce que c'est pas
obligé
déjà parce que il ya des gens à qui ça
plaît et puis surtout le plus important
si vous vous êtes bien avec vos cernes
changeait rien c'est pas dangereux
donc il ya les cernes creux les cernes
plein les cernes coloré et une dernière
catégorie
un petit peu à part dont je vous
parlerai à la fin les cernes creux
d'abord on va là le nom est assez
parlant c'est quand on a une espèce de
vide lahoud sous les yeux on dit qu'on a
les traits tirés ou les traits creusés
ça peut être causée par deux choses soit
on a beaucoup maigri et souvent on a
beaucoup maigri d'un coup soit on a
beaucoup vieilli
bah oui parce qu'avec l'âge les tissus
du visage ils ont tendance à s'affaisser
et là juste en dessous de l'oeil bas il
ya les orbites
c'est creux donc comme tout ça ça tient
plus sa épouse la forme et ça donne ce
genre de choses ça fait pas plaisir mais
c'est comme ça les cernes plan c'est ce
qu'on appelle communément des poches
sous les yeux ou des valises ou des
testicules
si c'est vraiment très gonflé non ça
c'est faux non en fait il ya deux cas de
figure ça peut être une sorte de deyme
c'est-à-dire de l'eau qui stagne sous la
peau pour résumer parce que le drainage
se fait moins bien mais ça on va y
revenir
ça peut être parce que vous êtes resté
longtemps sans bouger genre vous avez
mais profondément pendant très longtemps
là c'est normal de l'eau on en a un
petit peu partout dans le visage
elle est venue se coller là j'allais
vous lever à va se diffuser un petit peu
partout mais ça peut être aussi parce
que vous faites de la rétention d'eau à
cause d'une maladie ou d'un médicament
et si c'est pas un oedème ça peut être
la grèce qu'on a tout autour des yeux
qui s'appelle la grèce perry orbitaire
qui a coulé qui est descendue petit à
petit et qui est venu se coller la voix
souvent c'est à cause d'un relâchement
des tissus qui la maintenait en place ça
se fait progressivement et alors là on
en arrive au type de cernes qui vous
intéressent le plus je le sens bien
c'est les cernes coloré il ya toute une
jolie petite palette mais dans la
majorité des cas c'est lié à deux causes
la peau et la circulation sanguine la
peau en dessous les yeux elle fait
partie des plus fines du corps humain et
ce à deux conséquences
d'abord elle s'abîme facilement et
ensuite bas on voit bien ce qui se passe
en dessous et en dessous ya plein de
petits vaisseaux sanguins et aussi des
vaisseaux lymphatiques
alors les vaisseaux sanguins vous voyez
ce que c'est mais les vaisseaux
lymphatiques et ben les vaisseaux
lymphatiques leur boulot c'est de
drainer la lymphe qui est un liquide
chargé d'évacuer les déchets que nos
cellules rejette alors maintenant que
vous savez ça qu'est ce qu'on a comme
choix pour la couleur on a le modèle
rouge qui n'est pas celui qui se vend le
plus mais qu à son petit cachet quand ça
arrive quand on a les vaisseaux dilatés
soit temporairement parce qu on a chaud
par exemple soit de façon chronique et
vous souvenez la peau elle est fine et
les vaisseaux ils sont juste en dessous
donc ça soit on a aussi les marrons et
là je ne vous le cache pas les essayer
c'est les adopter
oui parce que dans ces cas là ce qui
cause la couleur c'est une accumulation
de pigments 1 comme la mélanine par
exemple qui est celle qui fait qu'on est
bronzée et kemal et vas tu es là c'est
souvent des causes héréditaires
c'est comme ça donc du coup c'est plutôt
chronique et pour finir notre b sert
alors celle là on en écoule l'adulte
quantité les bleu violacé
c'est celle là c'est ce qu'on a quand on
n'a pas assez dormi par exemple la
typiquement c'est un problème de
circulation
quand on est fatigué le sang circule
moins bien partout sauf que là à cet
endroit là ça se voit beaucoup plus
parce que encore une fois la peau est
très fine
le sang y stagne dans les vaisseaux sous
les yeux du coup les pigments qui
s'accumulent ils se dégradent et ça
donne cette couleur bleu violacé
ça peut s'accompagner d'un petit groupe
le mans parce que les vaisseaux
lymphatiques ne font pas leur boulot non
plus du coup la lymphe est simple si
vous voulez tout savoir il n'y a pas que
la fatigue qui complique le boulot de la
circulation il ya aussi le tabac
l'alcool le stress ce genre de choses
voilà maintenant que vous savez pourquoi
on a des cernes
sachez que suivant le type de cernes que
vous allez si vous voulez les faire
disparaître
il ya différents traitements en fonction
des causes ça va des injections en
passant par le laser voir la chirurgie
pour les cernes bleu du réveil le froid
c'est très bien ça stimule la
circulation sanguine et le drainage
lymphatique
donc ça évacue les pigments et ça fait
dégonfler donc vous pouvez poser ce lui
sourit alors avant de partir je vous
vois froncer les sourcils
non j'ai pas oublié cette petite
catégorie à part dont je vous ai parlé
au début ces trucs un peu à part cédé
xanthélasma énoncé par un modèle de
voiture ces espèces de petites taches
jaunes que certaines personnes peuvent
avoir autour des yeux je sais pas si
vous avez déjà c'est pas vraiment des
cernes c'est une accumulation de
cellules qui sont pleines de graisse de
lipides du cholestérol en fait et qui
viennent se mettre là sous les yeux ou
au dessus des fois c'est juju génétique
sans qu'ils aient un taux de cholestérol
trop élevé c'est pas dangereux en soi ça
risque pas de dégénérer ou quoi et là
encore on peut se les faire retirer si
on en ressent le besoin voilà dtc c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui si vous vous poser
ce genre de questions ou d'autres vous
pouvez me les envoyer à question dtc @
gmail point com
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous